tendresse des tracks je vous en pensez
vous il paraît que c'est normal cette
année ma vieille tante disait que
c'était tout ce qui tournait autour de
nous à votre avis c'est dû à quoi
il ya deux astrologue qui avait dit en
début d'année que la cause d'une planète
qui se frôlent la terre on doit avoir
une anna catastrophe à inondations à
pluie puis apparemment ils sont pas
trompés quoi le problème c'est que on
est à paris
j'arrive la tène j'ai pas eu de chance
trois jours de pluie sur un séjour de 7
jours
tous les ans c'est la même chose je
pense qu'il ya des bonnes et des
mauvaises années c'est tout
je savais juste qu'il fait à ses grilles
à paris je suis gêné dans le midi
jusqu'à l'aube du sud
je pense surtout que on a de moins en
moins de temps pour répondre à deux
questions justement sur le temps je
crois que ça va dans le sens actuel de
la politique on peut comparer la
politique et la saison
la pluie m'ennuie de plus en plus dont
je pense avec philosophie en espérant
qu'il fera quand même drôlement demain
après la pluie vient le beau temps après
la pluie vient le beau temps
alors là il n'y a plus de saisons et ce
qui est bien sûr bien sûr qu'il y a des
saisons on observe des moyens que l'on
vérifie depuis longtemps mais ce qui est
intéressant dans ces dans ce reportage
c'est sont tous les lieux communs que
l'on colporte sur le temps du jour s'ils
commettent ou c'est la bombe atomique ou
c'est les fusées ou c'est le voisin qui
fait du feu enfin bref et toujours on
cherche toujours des boucs émissaires
mais quand on fait les moyennes on
s'aperçoit que il y a toujours une une
moyenne comment dire autrement il ya
toujours un temps que l'on vérifie
depuis des dizaines et des dizaines
d'années les métaux national des
statistiques extrêmement précises là
dessus prenons un exemple un enfant qui
serait venu à la conscience de ça de ses
souvenirs en 1976 qu'est ce qu'il va
nous dire dans 30 ans il va nous dire
mais de mon temps il faisait chaud alors
que vous savez très bien que 76 et une
année exceptionnelle un enfant qui
viendraient maintenant à la conscience
de ses souvenirs qu'est ce qu'il va nous
dire il va nous dire après ce printemps
pourri qui a pulvérisé tous les records
du plus quoi dire de montants levés tout
le temps pourtant ce n'est pas vrai nous
avons vécu en 1976 à l'envers cette
année nous et dire que c'est très
subjectif et on garde seulement on ne
garde des images de légende comme les
bons souvenirs les jours de pluie passer
à la
maison les zoobles aulas et on a
tendance à dire il faisait beau oui
c'est ça c'est uniquement subjectif mais
vous savez ce n'est pas notre échelle
ce n'est pas notre échelle parce que
l'atmosphère elle a déjà 5 milliards
d'années
manas de la terre il y en a encore pour
5 milliards il encore il va s'en passer
des choses pendant 5 milliards d'années
tout ça n'est pas à notre échelle nous
c'est quoi 75 ans sont au maximum ce
n'est pas beaucoup pour ce faire elle a
le temps pour elle si un volcan explose
et crée une couche de poussière tout
autour du globe pour empêcher le soleil
de passer la terre s'en fiche elle a le
temps de le faire retomber ce nuage de
poussière mais nous le problème c'est
qu'on est dessous et on est plus en plus
frileux et on aime de plus en plus le
confort et on a de plus en plus de
congés et pendant ses congés
on veut avoir du beau temps et qu'il n'y
en a pas ça apparaît d'autant plus
dramatique ça c'est aussi l'évolution de
la société c'est un problème
sociologique donc donc il ya quand même
une moyenne du temps si on prend un
nombre d'années suffisamment étalé et
long les statistiques météorologiques
existent depuis combien de temps en
france avec un réseau métrologique
important 10 872 environ peu ou prou
mais vous savez ça fait longtemps qu'on
observe le temps bon alors